I was inspired to be an ocean Explorer
from a very young age we had a swimming
pool in my backyard and I put on a
little mask and fins and pretend I was
Jacques Cousteau or I was swimming with
sharks or dolphins or something
I had somewhat of an epiphany where I
would explore the ocean but I would do
it with a camera
Cortez banks about a hundred miles west
of San Diego California it's become
somewhat of an oasis for marine wildlife
diving in Cortez bankers is like diving
into an underwater kaleidoscope it's
always changing with light and color
gesture and motion and it's never the
same twice and I think if more people
come to see it and appreciate it then
it's a no brainer to say that we need to
protect
[Music]
we were out there in the boat one day
and a very rare species of dolphin the
northern right whale emerged on the
scene it was the species I had never
seen in my life
and it could have easily swam the other
way but they chose to come around and
spend some time with me they were
curious inquisitive and I was able to
make a handful of pictures that to me
are very special but also speak to this
broader issue of this place being an
oasis I also had some magical
experiences with Pacific white-sided
dolphins they had could have corralled a
little bait ball of half moon fish with
beautifully colored fish bit of a mirror
reflection on the calm ocean that day
absolutely stunning
[Music]
you know every time I go off on a fun
man it's the greatest day of my life and
it's also the most stressful day because
the great expectations exist you have to
come back with a National Geographic
story and you're going into the water
with like a hardware store on your back
and and carrying this big rig around and
you know you're fighting currents and
third and working with wildlife is
always particularly hard because you
can't control those things there's
nothing you can do about it but with
every dive you're meeting this
fascinating casket character and if
you're patient if you give it time you
get those moments you'd be able to make
those pictures and a lile viewer is a
glimpse into this very magical place
that I believe everybody should know
about
and I believe deserves to be protected
[Music]
Oh
[Music]